[Music]
ok ladies and gentlemen please welcome
the vice president of the United States
Al Gore
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. vice president we're very honored to
have you here and to have you as the
keynote of our first National Innovation
Summit and we particularly appreciate
the efforts you've made to get here and
flying in open overnight so thank you
very much for being with us
mit clearly is a appropriate site for
this first council initiative on
innovation mit is clearly a national
treasure both as an educational
institution and as a generator of new
knowledge and of course it's
particularly appropriate since Chuck
vest is our Vice Chair of the net of the
Council on competitiveness representing
the academic institutions and I think as
you know mr. vice president this council
is a unique organization it's comprised
of business labor academia leaders of
America really working together to
improve our nation's competitiveness and
from the beginning we have recognized
that government has a key role in in
that as well and we have worked closely
with him and we're very pleased that the
Clinton administration really recognized
this from its beginnings and has worked
closely with us on it now what brings us
here today the members of the council
with the governors and the congressional
leaders of both parties as well as
members of the administration is really
a shared belief that the competitive
challenges facing the United States have
changed and are changing a decade ago
the most pressing demands that face
companies like Xerox and many of our
other companies were to reduce costs to
improve quality to shorten our product
life cycles and these really were the
survival issues of that time but we have
made significant progress on these
challenges we as a nation are
significantly more competitive than we
were a decade ago that is documented in
the council's a ten-year report on
competitiveness and we really I believe
have done this by working together with
business labor academia and a government
but we are now facing a world economy
that is changing very dramatically it's
becoming more integrated the information
revolution has open
new frontiers our competitive nations
have noticed our improvement and in fact
focused on our success and have focused
on improving their technology and their
innovation process and as President
Clinton and you have eloquently pointed
out it's a new economy in which is a
higher premium and than ever on
translating new ideas into new products
and services that will win in the global
markets and support high wages at home
ladies and gentlemen no one in public
life has taken a more visible role and
lead than the Vice President Gore in
trying to understand and respond to the
new forces at work his interest and
knowledge of technology and innovation
process I think is well known to all of
us but I think many of us would be
surprised at the depth of his knowledge
and I've had this pointed out to me a
couple times both in the early days when
he was vice president-elect at the
economic summit in Little Rock but even
more clearly one time with the council
and sponsored with the Library of
Congress a small conference on the
Internet and the implications of the
Internet and this was attended by a
number of CEOs a number of government
leaders in a number of technologists and
I know speaking for a number of CEOs in
the audience given the dialogue between
the technologists and the vice president
we all went home and said we better get
another tutorial on the internet because
he clearly knows a lot more than we do
about that mr. vice president as you
know we are discussing and we'll discuss
more today the ten-year outlook for u.s.
innovation and the action steps that
could position could strengthen our
position in this regard and we are very
fortunate that our dialogue will be
informed by your perspective and of
course we hope to continue to engage you
in a concerted effort after this
innovation conference to strengthen our
country and strengthen our nation ladies
and gentlemen the Vice President Al Gore
thank you very much no please thank you
thank you very much thank you ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much for your
kindness and Paul thank you for your
very generous introduction I've really
enjoyed working with you over the years
and I want to say what a personal debt I
owe to Paul Allaire for being my tutor
when I began the reinventing government
project for President Clinton and he and
a few others came and gave me some
lessons that were absolutely invaluable
in getting that started and I want to
acknowledge the other leaders of of this
summit here this meeting Chuck vest is a
longtime friend and outstanding
president of this institution Bill
Hambrick chairman of the council and
John yochelson a President of the
Council on competitiveness George Fisher
a chairman and CEO of the Eastman Kodak
I was just looking at iridium latest
project progress yesterday from his
former company John Young the founder of
the council who's met with President
Clinton and me on so many occasions and
serves as a co-chair of the President's
Council on science and technology
advisors and Jack Shankman the vice
chair of the council representing the
perspective of labor and Sandy Fellman
who is is here from the aft and a great
friend and an ally and also to the
members of Congress who were here I want
to acknowledge my friend Nancy Pelosi
Vernon Ahlers and my former colleagues
on the Science and Technology Committee
Jim Sensenbrenner and George Brown who I
see through the lights here I see Jim
and George is here somewhere over here I
served on the House Science and
Technology Committee for eight years and
learned a lot from these two gentlemen
and we work together to form a
bipartisan support of base of support
for
search and development and measures to
improve the competitiveness of our
country and it's great to to see them
here too governor Zell Miller of Georgia
and Governor John Engler of Michigan
thank you too very much
I'll have another reference to Governor
Miller in in a moment I want to
especially thank Dan Goldin who as you
heard from his presentation a moment ago
is a real visionary and he and I have
worked together since I presided over
his confirmation hearings when I was on
the Senate science subcommittee a part
of the Senate Commerce Committee and
back in the last administration and we
have had a wonderful working
relationship and he does a truly
outstanding job and I want to
acknowledge our former Secretary of
Defense bill Perry who's around here
somewhere and a great partner and friend
and there are all kinds of other
distinguished guests I probably ought to
to acknowledge but I don't know to to do
it without accidentally missing people
so I'll just go right on to what I have
to say here and I'd like to start that
by telling you what a pleasure it is to
be back with the Council on
competitiveness and it's great to be
back here at MIT I haven't spoken here
in almost two years it'll be two years
ago June when I was asked to give the
commencement address I really enjoyed
that and I told the story at that time
about a great tragedy that occurred when
the founder of MIT after 20 years after
his retirement came back in 1882 to
deliver the commencement address and
it's a true story right in the middle of
his speech he dropped dead now you see
you're laughing but as terrible as that
is I was I noted then I was comforted by
the fact that no matter how I performed
I would be remembered as only the second
stiffest speaker and the
three of those commencement addresses
and now I can't I can't get away from
that I you know the Academy Awards are
coming up and the Good Will Hunting
which takes place at MIT is among the
nominees anyway last year when they had
the Academy Awards it made a real
impression on me because my wife tipper
and I were propped up on pillows in the
bed watching the telecast and Billy
Crystal the host came out with to start
the show with a an Oscar on the podium
and he mentioned that there were so many
people nominated and only a few would
win he cautioned them against
disappointment and he looked right into
the camera and he said remember the only
person who's guaranteed to wake up
tomorrow morning with a statue is tipper
gore
[Laughter]
as Groucho Marx once said I resemble
that remark anyway I'm very grateful to
this Council on competitiveness for
convening this critical national summit
and very grateful for the important work
you have done for so long and especially
during this past year because you've
been helping us understand the dramatic
changes that are taking place throughout
our economy and throughout our society
not only in the United States but
throughout the world and as someone with
a longtime interest in innovation and
it's considerable economic benefits I
have followed the work of this council
since its founding a dozen years ago you
all came back when others were in your
positions now and testified before our
House Science and Technology Committee
Jim and George and I had interchanges
back then you've shaped policy for a
long time
I remember in chairing the Senate
science subcommittee we frequently had
testimony from this council and over the
years like water on stone you have worn
away some of the resistance you
encountered at first and we've still got
a ways to go as a nation as you continue
to point out very forcefully but we are
making some changes in under President
Clinton's leadership we've seen some
pretty significant changes but the
fundamental reality remains our economy
is now driven by innovation and as
Michel Porter's that talk and study
pointed out other nations are really
moving rapidly to take advantage of the
new ability to innovate that is out
there we are obviously at the dawn of a
true innovation age it's almost a cliche
to point out the sequence from
agriculture to industry to information
but the change is accelerating
consider these facts it's estimated that
the entire store of human knowledge now
doubles every five years for example
we're just a few years away from the
complete sequencing of the human genome
giving us for the very first time a kind
of instruction manual for the human body
when that human genome is completed it
will have a gestalt effect the whole
will be considerably larger and more
important than the sum of its parts
just as the internet when it was
completed to the point where everyone
could connect into it acquired a
significance far larger than the
incremental advance that completed the
last accessibility in the same way we're
going to see a whole revolution in
genetics and biotechnology even beyond
what is going on right now when the
human genome is finally completed and
it's so it's so close within a couple of
years microchips will routinely contain
1 billion transistors per chip the size
of a fingernail and the patterns etched
onto them will be as complex and
complicated as the roadmap for the
entire planet that's difficult to
comprehend and the implications are of
course vast I mentioned iridium from
George's old company within six months I
think they've got 42 satellites up now
the constellation of 66 would be rounded
out in early September they'll have a
couple of weeks of a shake out time by
the end of September this year it will
be possible to make a cell cellular
telephone call from any point on the
surface of this planet to any other
point on the surface of this planet and
soon after there will be multiple
competing systems offering the same
service within three years it will be
possible to receive from any point
on the surface of this planet
information flows of six-and-a-half
gigabits compared to like 36 million
bits necessary for faxes and pagers and
telephone service it will be possible to
get six and a half gigabits six and half
billion bits of information flowing down
remotely Wireless to any place on the
surface of the earth what that means is
that access to the information
superhighway will be available from the
sands of the Kalahari from the top of
Mount Everest from any place on the
surface of the earth now what are the
implications obviously they're so vast
that it's impossible to predict what
that will happen nobody could predict
all of the changes that flowed from the
invention of the printing press and the
ubiquitous availability of information
to average citizens when books could be
printed when it's possible to have full
internet access for all of the five and
a half by then six almost six billion
people on on this planet the the
consequences are going to be really
staggering we're on the verge of
fulfilling a vision outlined by
Nathaniel Hawthorne in the middle of the
last century fifteen years after the
invention of the Telegraph he wrote
these words by means of electricity the
world of matter has become a great nerve
vibrating thousands of miles in a
breathless point of time the round globe
is a vast brain instinct with
intelligence often it's easy to chart
the exact benefits of a new breakthrough
to our health care to our pocketbooks to
our hard disk drives but today I'd like
to briefly talk about innovation in a
broader context and to talk about
innovation not merely as a material goal
but as an ethic a constant concern a
continuing focus for our entire country
some of you
as managers are familiar with the the
phrase learning organization some of you
manage toward that objective we as a
nation must be a learning nation we have
to put into place the infrastructure the
policies the programs and the habits
that enable us to continue innovating at
an accelerating rate mi t--'s motto mins
at Manas mind and hand sums up this
challenge true innovation encompasses
not only the labor of our hands but also
the labor of our minds increasingly of
course brain replaces brawn and if
American industry is to continue growing
and thriving and remaining competitive
we must be willing to think and act anew
to keep pushing the boundaries of
knowledge and discovery and to reshape
our economy by redefining the way we
view our world Thomas Kuhn wrote a
path-breaking study many years ago about
the way revolutions in thought occur all
of a sudden new observations new
findings about the world don't fit into
the old models that we're using and then
slowly these unexplainable observations
accumulate to the point where the old
model doesn't work anymore
and then all of a sudden someone comes
up with an innovative new pattern that
explains the UH the previously
unexplainable and produces a new vision
into which all of the information that
was mysterious in the past fits neatly
at a few precious moments in our history
we see this occur in a dramatic way more
than five hundred years ago a Columbus
set sail and obviously by discovering
the new world he gave us a new vision of
Earth Copernicus was 19 years old when
Columbus landed in the New World and
just a few years after that just a
couple of decades after that rather he
produced the new model explaining not
only the earth but its relationship to
the solar system in a new way a century
after Columbus Galileo first turned the
new instrument of the telescope toward
the sky and shattered centuries-old
notions about the mechanics of our solar
system and obviously the I mean I saw a
cartoon recently maybe it was in the
Wall Street Journal about with the
Columbus speaking to Queen Isabella and
saying and not only will we find spices
this will create 3,000 new jobs and I
you know I think sometimes we we sound
like that a little bit and for obvious
reasons but the discoveries coming out
of the Age of Exploration unleashed the
greatest explosion of trade and commerce
the the world had ever seen new lands
brought new ideas and the need for new
inventions Europe's contact with other
cultures and customs while not always
mutually positive stimulated new
thinking in the old world now half a
millennium after Columbus in our time we
broke free from the gravitational pull
of the earth with the Apollo program and
we went to explore the surface of the
Moon but in doing so we dramatically
change the way we viewed ourselves and
our own planet dan knows that in in my
office in the in the White House my
office is down the hall from the Oval
Office I I work in the famous square
office in the in the White House and on
the on the wall is a is a photograph of
the earth that was taken on December 7th
9th
72 by the very last Apollo mission to
the moon it is the most printed
photograph in the history of humankind
the people who keep up with those things
say the next closest photograph is not
even close
I remember when the Apollo 8 mission
first circled the moon before Apollo 11
landed and the image of the Earth from
space had a dramatic impact some people
anticipated that the great british
astrophysicist Fred Hoyle predicted in
1948 in these words once a photograph of
the Earth taken from outside is
available once the sheer isolation of
the earth becomes plain a new idea as
powerful as any in history will be let
loose of course it wasn't until the
Apollo missions exactly 20 years later
that we found out the truth of that
prophecy like a child's first glimpse of
herself in a mirror those photographs
changed our own self-image we saw a
world that was not as vast or expansive
or incomprehensible as we had thought
but surprisingly smaller more
interconnected and more fragile the poet
Archibald MacLeish wrote of those images
to see the earth as we see it now small
and blue and beautiful in that eternal
silence where it floats is to see
ourselves as writers on the earth
together brothers on the bright
loveliness in the unending night
brothers who see now they are truly
brothers this new image this new way of
integrating knowledge shifted centuries
of human understanding and brought about
dramatic results certainly such a
quantum leap in our worldview does not
occur all that often but when it does it
sometimes
takes decades to know where the leap is
taking us and in that spirit it's not
that different from the work that many
of you do each and every day pushing the
ever-expanding boundaries of knowledge
and discovery creating and innovating
for the ultimate benefit of all of our
people at its heart what innovation
means is looking at the world in new and
different ways our challenge is to
create the right climate for that kind
of innovation both large and small and
to harness its enormous economic
potential for the 21st century
you've already come a long way and with
help from so many of you our nation is
building a new economy one that takes
innovation as its starting point not as
a mere byproduct the new economy is
driven by innovation information and
Technology are its fuels the new economy
values the productivity and creativity
of people above all else yesterday
I had long sessions in Silicon Valley
with the Prime Minister of Russia Viktor
Chernomyrdin and the CEOs of many of the
leading high technology firms some of
you all couldn't be there because you
were on your way here for this for this
meeting bill Perry was one in that
category bill Hambrick there's some
others but we had quite a representation
from the high tech community there and
they made it plain to the leadership of
Russia what we already know which is
that by far the most valuable resource
or asset that any nation has is the
unused creativity and brainpower of the
men and women in that nation Russia has
more PhDs per capita than any nation on
the face of this earth you talk about an
innovation policy they need one and we
do too and there there are a lot of
things that it is now obvious with this
new world view we need to be doing right
now the new economy is connected to the
global marketplace where we zap dollars
and date around the world at the speed
of light now today we do have some
things going for us the American economy
is once again the envy of the world
interest rates and inflation are at
record lows investment and modernization
are both rising we have 15 million new
jobs the lowest unemployment in a
generation and today a full third of our
GDP growth now comes from information
technology our fast-growing
environmental technology industry is
already bigger than our steel industry
textile industry or aerospace industry
more Americans build semiconductors now
than construction machinery more
Americans spend their days processing
data than refining petroleum more
Americans now build computers than build
cars perhaps more importantly today
there is left less difference between
the task of building a computer and
building a car open up a car and it
doesn't look a lot different than some
computers today's Ford Taurus has more
computing power than those Apollo
spacecraft in the 1960s and and 70s and
those that build cars do so in ways that
emphasize quality performance and
innovation part of what we used to call
and some still call the Japanese
challenge came about because they
figured out how to innovate new
generations of products like cars in a
much shorter period of time they they
took the lead time from the idea for a
new car from that point to the
appearance of the new car from seven
years down to five years down to three
years and there's a great race on now to
get that process down to two one year
some of the technologies that Dan Goldin
referred to will be important in that
process already in the aircraft
manufacturing industry Boeing is leading
the entire world because it has figured
out how to use some of the new
Meishan technologies to compress that
development period down to the bare
minimum the triple seven as many of you
know was created without any paper to
speak off completely in digital form and
the maintenance can be done digitally as
well
they're telescoping that lead time from
idea to the appearance of the product
really across the board and our own
automobile industries companies are are
now on the verge of creating the largest
most powerful extra net in in the world
to connect with their suppliers and
subcontractors and move toward digital
paperless information flows in the
development of new vehicles we are
working with the big three in the
partnership for a new generation of
vehicles to move beyond the internal
combustion engine toward a new
generation of vehicles that will have
much higher levels of efficiency will be
much more cost competitive with much
lower levels of pollution among the
other advantages now these two examples
illustrate the convergence of
technologies that is now giving us the
ability to get productivity gains from
computers long after their initial
introduction we know from history that
sometimes innovations are exciting and
obviously important but don't bring any
measurable improvements in productivity
for quite some time some of you are
familiar with the example of what
happened when new electric motors were
invented and introduced people thought
that they would bring improvements in
productivity but they didn't at least
not for a while
why because the context into which they
were introduced had not changed in order
to accommodate the new potential the old
factories from the Industrial Age were
designed for steam engines and that
meant that many of them were highly
highly vertical with conveyor belts and
loops coming off the the central source
of power in the middle of the factory
when they retrofitted factories like
that with small electric motors the
inherent efficiencies in the electric
motors couldn't be seen anywhere but
over time that those physical plants
wore out new factories were built and
designed in a way that accommodated the
inherent efficiencies of that new
technology and so after a long delay all
of a sudden there was a surge in
productivity because the inherent
advantages were able to be expressed in
the new context that was created I think
we're seeing something exactly like that
now with the delayed productivity gains
from the introduction of micro
processors and computers and networks as
businesses and industries now redesign
their physical plants and more
importantly their processes and their
human interactions in ways that take
advantage of the new abilities conferred
by micro processing that's why I
sometimes wonder about the measurements
that are used on innovation and
productivity we have to make do with
what measurements so we can get our
hands on but this is inherently a very
inexact process and those of you who've
spent a long time studying
Activity know that it's just the the
studies are just a mess there just so
many factors involved and some people
will have great precision and saying
this or that about it and and we again
we have to work with the information
available but sometimes you can
introduce some new capacities that you
know are gonna fuel a surge in
productivity even if it's not measured
for a while look at the Internet when we
started providing seed money in the
Congress more than 20 years ago for the
development of what is now the internet
there was there was no enthusiasm in the
business community for it because it was
it was not relevant to the way business
operated at the time now of course every
business has its own webpage and whole
industries are being redesigned in order
to take full advantage of the abilities
of the internet when President Clinton
and I took office there were only 50
sites on the world wide web that hadn't
been that long ago just five little over
five years ago and now of course
millions and millions and the increase
is geometric it is some it is an example
of a new capacity a new way of linking
together a new convergence a new way of
seeing the world that after a delay
produces a surge of productivity in fact
if you think back on that example of the
electric motors what happened there was
when alternating current was invented it
made it made it possible to distribute
electricity over a much wider area and
and then it was possible with electric
motors to distribute the sources of
mechanical energy throughout the factory
and co-locate them precisely where each
machine needed the mechanical energy
in exactly that same way what the
internet is making possible is a new
form of distributed intelligence
distributed knowledge distributed
information and all of the old
organizational structures which like
those vertical factories based on the
steam engines relied on a central
repository for knowledge with all the
decisions having to go to that central
place now the knowledge is distributed
widely and easily and geographic
boundaries are not as significant as
they once were Microsoft has a contract
in India for maintenance and service so
that when you call the number they may
take care of it in Seattle or without
knowing it you may be talking to someone
in in India over the internet and
receiving the information seamlessly as
if it was coming from Redmond Washington
and of course many of you here could
give similar examples but the point is
today's technology is allowing us to
unlock a much higher fraction of that
unused creativity among men and women
all over our nation and we're able to
reach out to those who in previous years
would have been left out of the world of
innovation now we never know where we
will find the person responsible for the
next intellectual breakthrough it could
be a janitor right here at MIT you can't
you can't ever tell some of you saw the
movie
there's simply no question that if we
want to make the most of the 21st
century and this new economy if we want
to achieve the full promise of American
business we have to do everything we can
to fuel new innovation and discovery
build partnerships that encourage
support and reward cutting-edge ideas
and keep our economy strong enough and
efficient enough to take advantage of
them as quickly as possible
I along with my colleagues I've worked
on initiatives to try to take advantage
of these new realities the Small
Business Innovation research initiative
the first legislation which led to the
internet the first funding for the human
genome project and the rest and over the
past five years under President
Clinton's leadership we have done an
enormous amount to encourage innovation
for a for a quarter of a century the
number of patent applications for
inventions by Americans hovered between
60,000 and 70,000 per year that was true
for most of the 1980s the past few years
have seen that number jump up to above
100,000 similarly we've increased the
number of patent awards by 50 percent
from the early 1980s we plan to seize
that promise by continuing the bold new
economic strategy that we believe is
partly responsible for the surge of
strength in the new economy eliminating
the deficit opening up new markets to
our products and investing more in
education technology job training and
Environmental Protection and other
efforts which help to secure our future
on the first point we will balance the
budget and will we will do it this year
the budget the president just proposed
to Congress takes the deficit that used
to have 1100 that is very important when
you look at access to credit it's an old
story to describe what it was like for
companies to compete in credit markets
with the 800-pound gorilla that had to
get 300 billion dollars a year or more
in order to finance the federal deficit
so we made tough choices based on hard
numbers and freed up hundreds of
billions of dollars in capital to
finance private investments including
research and development and one of the
other reasons for our emphasis on
eliminating the deficit is not only the
competition and credit markets but also
the simple fact that in this new economy
we're not on the gold standard we're on
the
information standard and we get a
premium in world credit markets and
finance markets when they see that the
economy is being managed well investment
capital is flowing toward the United
States we're seeing an expression of
confidence all over the world in US
markets we need to go further and
increase the savings rate that's a very
complicated challenge as your council
has made clear over the years but we
must do our best to meet that challenge
now the second component of our economic
strategy after having a sound fiscal
policy is to keep on opening markets for
American products overseas 96% of the
consumers in the world live in other
countries that's why we've signed more
than 200 new trade agreements in the
past few years and we're pushing hard
for the authority to enter into yet more
trade agreements
we're also aggressively addressing
unfair trade practices by other nations
we're insisting upon the protection of
intellectual property rights I just had
lengthy discussions with Prime Minister
chair Namir Dan over the last three days
for example on that point and we're
putting in place mechanisms to help to
address the concerns of at-risk workers
as we move ever farther into this global
marketplace the third part of our
economic strategy is making those
targeted investments in the future and
that means first and foremost
dramatically improving our K through 12
education system and that's why we're
after hiring a hundred thousand new
police officers to help bring the crime
rate down we're now proposing measures
to hire a hundred thousand new
high-quality
teachers to reduce classroom sizes
that's why we're trying to connect every
single classroom and library to the
information superhighway that's why
we're trying to finance the construction
and renovation of crumbling classrooms
and school buildings all over the United
States that's why we're pushing national
standards for for math and reading
that's why we're setting specific
national goals that's why we're calling
for voluntary national tests you can ask
any classroom of students whether or not
they study harder if they know the test
is coming up and the answer is of course
yes well if we have tests against which
we can measure progress or the lack of
progress we're going to have an easier
time figuring out whether we're moving
in the right direction or whether we're
moving in the wrong direction we have to
invest in the improvements to our
education system we've already freed up
more money for access to higher
education than at any time since the
passage of the GI Bill and we we are
addressing the problems in our job
training system we've called as part of
the initial reinventing government
report we call for the elimination of
all of the various and complicated job
training programs and the replacement of
all of them with a voucher system to to
really streamline the job training
marketplace I want to say that I
encourage every single one of you to
look closely at an innovation that
Governor Zell Miller has put in place in
Columbus Georgia called the ipact
mechanism that brings together
universities community leaders and the
business community to dramatically
change higher education in a technical
school format to produce highly relevant
sophisticated skills that are
immediately redeemable in the
marketplace it is the single most
innovative model that I have seen and of
course we took the HOPE scholarship
model from a governor Miller now we're
stealing this from him we're trying to
give him credit for it like we did the
hope scholarships but I really encourage
you all to look at that now investing in
the future also means investing in
research and development that's why
we're proposing the 21st century
research fund to have the largest
increases by far in funding for the
National Science Foundation the National
Institutes of Health the National Cancer
Institute and our other research in
that we've ever had in American history
we believe that in the innovation age
basic research must be financed by the
people of this country through the
institutions of self-government simply
because of the obvious reason that
for-profit enterprises because of
competition are necessarily going to
have to focus on research that has more
immediate applications and that's why
we're investing not just in targeted
research but also in the undirected
research that often yields the largest
long-term gains of course that it takes
private-sector investment as well and we
have to understand that even though
there are new efficiencies and research
and development with computational
science and the internet the new
advantages that supercomputers give
still the basic costs for research and
development are increasing and so we've
proposed an extension of America's two
point two billion dollar research and
experimentation Tax Credit which is
critical to our most innovative
industries and we're encouraging other
policies that free up more funding for
private research and development now
part of our strategy is also to
unshackle the dynamism of the new
economy by freeing it from the heavy
hand of old outdated obsolete government
practices I've referred a couple of
times to a reinventing government I'll
give you a couple of examples
we're fighting to streamline the patent
law and we've proposed to take the
patent office
and make it what we call a
performance-based organization to get
rid of the bureaucracy of the past the
red tape the regulations have a CEO have
performance measures have strict
accountability set it up as a
performance-based organization and let
it go we think by focusing on results
and giving increased flexibility to a
managers and making other specific
changes we can bring about the kind of
transformation in government
organizations that many of you have
brought
in your private companies already we
have reduced the size of the federal
government by 350,000 people in the last
five years it is now smaller in size
than it has been since 1961 the first
year of President John Kennedy's
administration and it's smaller as a
percentage of the workforce than it was
since before the New Deal we've
eliminated 200 outdated government
programs eliminated more than 16,000
pages of red tape saved 137 billion
dollars in the process but we need
further improvements in regulatory
reform and in legal reform we need to
advance rapidly by using these new
understandings and new techniques now
we're paying special attention to the
growth and development of the Internet
we believe that the new economy is in
many ways an internet economy we have an
aggressive strategy to foster electronic
commerce trade and commerce on the
Internet are now tripling every year and
in just a few years we will be
generating hundreds of billions of
dollars in the sales of goods and
services we want to ensure the
establishment of an environment in which
electronic commerce can grow and
flourish so that every computer can be a
window open to every business large and
small everywhere in the world that means
minimal government no new taxes and no
cumbersome regulation that's why we're
working to make the internet a global
free trade zone to take advantage of its
full potential for stimulating
prosperity and our 21st century research
fund invests hundreds of millions of
dollars to help speed up the development
of the next generation internet which
will have data flows more than a
thousand times greater than the present
Internet and soon after that we will
increase it by another thousandfold just
imagine what the next generation can
help us achieve with data moving a
thousand times faster and having that
wireless access all over the globe just
three years from now I believe this
overall approach is one that will
definitely improve America
future competitiveness and I wish to
give credit to this council for
generating many of the the basic ideas
upon which our strategy has been based
this dialogue you've been having with
our nation over the last dozen years has
really been paying off and I encourage
you to continue the kind of forward
thinking that you have been up to before
I close I'd like to say that today I
would want to issue a specific challenge
that I hope will advance the discovery
process and give us a little bit richer
understanding of the world that we
inhabit I referred at the beginning of
my speech to Columbus's voyage according
to historians a Spanish sailor named
rodrigo de Triana was standing in the
forecastle of the Pinta Columbus's ship
and was the first person to see the new
world today a clearer view of our own
world could help us reach new heights of
understanding and that's why today I'm
proposing that NASA launched a satellite
named Triana which will provide the very
first continuous live images of the
entire Earth from space it will bring
into the digital age those remarkable
pictures we received of our earth a
generation ago you know that picture I
referred to was taken 26 years ago there
hasn't been one since then actually
there was for a brief moment a short
video of the earth as the Galileo
spacecraft was speeding away from the
earth and it turned around and focused
it kept its cameras on the earth and for
just a few seconds we were able to see
for just a short time I should say when
it was speeded up that the film is very
short but then it was gone and the
reason we don't have any other pictures
is that images from Earth orbit even
from the geosynchronous
orbit twenty two thousand three hundred
miles high just allows us to see a tiny
part of the Earth's surface the angle
interferes with our ability to see the
entire planet as you would from that
simulated view I'd like to show this
video illustrating the the idea behind
this satellite that I'm challenging NASA
to launch the first picture in this
video is the one that I described from
December of 1972 on the Apollo 17
mission you can see Antarctica at the
bottom it's the last picture we've had
of the earth except as I mentioned for
this brief stunning imagery as the
Galileo spacecraft left the earth
wouldn't it be nice to have that image
continuous live 24 hours a day we can
understand weather systems better if we
do now we'll be able to with this
project which will launch this small
satellite from the space shuttle bay
that's one of the options and then it
will be sped toward a point in space
between beyond the moon between the
earth and the Sun the Sun is Gino's 96
million miles away 1 million miles from
the earth just shy of that there is a
point called the l1 point where the
gravitational fields of the Earth and
Sun cancel each other out and this
satellite can be positioned there to
focus a high-definition television
camera on the earth and send images down
to students by way of the internet will
be able to study the movement of weather
systems in a brand-new way understanding
our understanding of phenomena like El
Nino can be vastly improved if we can
see farther into the Pacific Ocean where
the storms develop this is a this is a
imagery that is very difficult to piece
together from the current weather
satellites the this that's digitally
stitched together from a lot of
different geosynchronous weather
satellites it'll come down to three
university-based earth stations and then
made available world
through the internet and the launch will
take place in less than two years if
this is successful we will have live
twenty four-hour-a-day coverage of the
earth within less than two years I
believe that this can have tremendous
scientific value and help us to
understand the emergence of global
weather patterns and help us in a lot of
other ways as Socrates said 2,500 years
ago man must rise above the earth to the
top of the atmosphere and beyond for
only thus will he fully understand the
world in which he lived in different
words a former friend of some of us here
the astronaut rusty Schweickart once
described what he felt during the Apollo
series when he was orbiting the moon and
he said you realize that on that small
spot that little blue and white thing is
everything that matters to you all of
history and music and poetry and art and
war and death and birth and love tears
joy games all of it is on that little
spot out there that you can cover with
your thumb with triana that same
experience could be available to all of
us and as Columbus's reputed to have
said it will also produce 3,000 jobs
Daniel Boorstin the great former
librarian of Congress wrote the most
promising words ever written on the maps
of human knowledge are terra incognita
unknown territory that's true of our
ability to understand the earth our
effort to understand the new economy
it's true of your efforts to understand
how we can stimulate more innovation in
the United States of America I'm proud
to say that President Clinton and I are
ready and willing partners in the effort
to stimulate more innovation in the US
economy we will do every
we can to keep growth and innovation
high and productivity strong so let us
continue to blaze new paths to American
competitiveness continue to search for
uncharted territories be they near or
far and in the spirit of this great
institution let us apply our hands and
our minds and our hearts to that
endeavor for that is how we will build
the 21st century and the new economy of
our dreams thank you very much
[Applause]